apparently once you reach 100% brain
capacity you can use the force I need to
get me some of this drug limitless
I mean Lucy is directed by Luke based on
star Scarlett Johansson and Morgan
Freeman this film is about a girl who
gets a packet of drugs sewn inside of
her she's forced by these drug dealers
to conceal this drug within her and when
it pops open inside of her this new drug
gets into her bloodstream and allows her
to access an increasing amount of her
brain capacity she becomes incredibly
smart she's able to control electronics
and access people's brains and all kinds
of crazy stuff and she turns the tables
on these guys that forced her into this
situation no I do like Luke Faison
although a lot of his films are very
similar he really likes his badass
chicks La Femme Nikita the professional
the Fifth Element Lucy he really digs
girls with guns and Scarlett Johansson
is very good at doing that in this movie
in fact her performance is great she
starts off as this blubbering idiot she
does a total 180 and turns into the
ultimate hardcore badass and she does a
really good job in this film Morgan
Freeman plays Morgan Freeman in this
movie in fact it's pretty much the same
role that he played in transcendence
another scientific key movie about
technology and things existing that
don't quite exist in people making
things exist that don't quite exist
except this is much better than
transcendence Luc Besson makes a very
good-looking movie here the movie looks
great it's edited very well there's a
good car chase the action is filmed well
there isn't any stupid shaky cam
everything looks very nice and fluid all
the performances are very good in this
movie the dude from old boy whose name I
can never pronounce correctly did a very
good job as well although you don't
really know much about his character
he's just a menacing evil guy and you
don't really know much else about him at
all but he was good it has all the loot
based on cliches you're expecting to see
you know guns and slow-motion and opera
music and stuff but for a movie about
someone who is incredibly smart it has a
lot of dumb parts too I just find it
stupid that someone who is able to
access a hundred percent of their brain
capacity would not see the incredible
futility of gun violence she can do
everything and it
she can actually control things and use
like telekinesis and stuff yet she's
still doing the guns and it's like
why but my main issue with this movie
was actually the fact that as a
protagonist she becomes so invincible
that no one challenges her she can do
anything everyone is a weak little wisp
of something to her so there isn't
really that much tension in the movie
it's just kind of an entertaining film
that you can watch but there really
isn't that
white-knuckled fear that you may have
wanted from an action movie because
she's basically a superhero my best way
to describe it to you is the first
matrix film versus the last two Matrix
films
never in the first film where it was
like really gritty and actually kind of
violent neo is getting his ass handed to
him he was spitting up blood and
everything and you cared about him you
were worried about his survival and
reloaded in revolutions he was such a
super hero when he got hit in the face
it was like always fine it's not a
problem he never really felt that
tension cuz he was just able to control
everything and he was better than
everyone that same issue is with Lucy
because she is able to control
everything she is better than everyone
and so you don't really fear for her
survival there isn't an antagonist in
this movie that is worthy of her so the
antagonist in the movie the villain is
just kind of a really evil guy it is a
very bizarre movie as well it's very
ambitious actually in fact a lot more
ambitious than you may think by just
watching the trailers in fact so
ambitious that I think some audience
members will be turned off by this movie
because it actually does a lot of really
unconventional things with this movie
despite the fact that there's a lot of
conventional action genre cliches as
well use a lot of animal footage and
things like that to give very obvious
visual metaphors the things you are
seeing happening it's really cut it's
like I was like oh it's different and I
guess that's kind of praiseworthy to
have the ball so do something that
different in a movie that audience
members might not like or understand the
movie is entertaining Johansson is great
in the movie it looks very very good
there are a good action sequences
despite the fact the tension really
isn't there and there's a lot of really
dumb dumb dumb things that happen in
this movie about someone who's really
smart I'm gonna give Lucy a b-minus it's
a mixed bag at times but overall I was
entertained by the movie and I think if
you go into the movie just wanting to be
entertained you'll probably enjoy
yourself but
yourself because it is a little
different and a little bit more
ambitious than you may have thought if
you just watch the trailer and thoughts
it's just going to be luke Poisson
action movie with guns and bullets and
babes in slow motion and it has that but
it also has other things that I won't
spoil guys have you seen this film let
me know what you think of it below if
you're excited for it I'd like to hear
about it thank you so much as always for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck my
next